il ya eu un choix délibéré est conscient
de lancer la guerre quand nous pouvions
encore négocier la paix déclarations du
chef de l'état français manuel macron
qui s'est entretenu rapidement avec le
président russe vladimir poutine il lui
a demandé de mettre fin aux combats mais
il laisse ouvert le chemin que heures du
dialogue avec moscou on retrouve alix
bourdon notre correspondante à bruxelles
quelle est l'efficacité des sanctions à
court terme et à moyen terme
et de l'écouté d'après les européens ce
deuxième train de sanctions va avoir un
effet sévère et massif alors il est vrai
que c'est sans que ces sanctions vont
toucher plusieurs secteurs l'énergie le
transport et la banque et puis l'union
européenne veut également restreindre
l'accès de la russie à certaines
technologies de pointe comme certains
composants électroniques et certaines
technologique de 1 raffinage alors ce
deuxième train de sanctions il vient
donc s'ajouter à un premier train de
sanctions qui a été pris mercredi des
mesures qui visent des entreprises et
des personnalités impliquées dans
l'escaladé militaire comme les
parlementaires de la douma alors hier
les chefs d'état et de gouvernement ont
également parlé des prochaines étapes
art c'est à dire un troisième train de
sanctions qui pourraient justement
inclure des mesures que les européens
n'ont pas encore pris 1 comme
l'exclusion de la russie du système
bancaire swift 1 ça vous le savez c'est
une demande de l'ukraine mais certains
pays européens sont réticents comme
l'allemagne ou comme l'italien puisque
ce système bancaire swift est utilisé en
notamment pour les approvisionnements en
gaz il pourrait dans ce troisième train
de sanctions il y avoir aussi des
mesures qui viseraient plus durement les
oligarques russes proche de vladimir
poutine des mesures qu'ils aient
viserait directement au portefeuille et
puis on peut aussi parler de mesures
individuelles qui viserait vladimir
poutine lui même mais on peut en effet
en se poser l'efficacité à se poser la
question de l'efficacité de toutes ces
mesures puisque vous le savez un la
russie
est déjà sous le coup de sanctions
depuis 2014 et l'annexion de la crimée
et depuis 2014 et bien vadimir poutine a
préparé son pays et la russie a appris à
produire plus et a importé - le pays est
devenu par exemple le premier
exportateur mondial de blé il ya eu
aussi la dédollarisation du système
bancaire et puis la russie a également
cherché à baisser sa dépendance
vis-à-vis des occidentaux en se tournant
vers d'autres puissances comme la chine
et le président ukrainien vient de
réagir ils appellent l'union européenne
justement à alourdir les sanctions
contre la russie vladimir poutine va
réagir quelles vont être les
conséquences pour les européens
est bien la russie 1 c'est d'abord vous
le savez une relation commerciale
importante pour les européens puisque
moscou représente le cinquième marché
d'exportation pour l'union européenne et
c'est aussi le troisième plus gros
fournisseur du continent après les états
unis et la chine une relation
commerciale qui compte pour les
européens mais qui comptent plus pour la
russie inde a presque déclaré fin
janvier ou sous la forme d'un 'lion' la
présidente de la commission européenne
qui a rappelé que l'ua l'union
européenne est le premier investisseur
en russie mais en effet un ces sanctions
pourraient se retourner contre les
européens vladimir poutine pourrait
décider de mettre un terme par exemple
aux exportations de blé ce qui n'aurait
pas d'effet immédiat sur la consommation
mais ce qui pourrait provoquer une
hausse des prix sur le marché en europe
et puis il ya évidemment on sait la
question du gaz moscou est à l'origine
de plus de 40% des importations
européennes et la crainte évidemment
c'est que des mesures de rétorsion rue
c'est bien de se fassent ressentir sur
la facture d'énergie des européens merci
beaucoup alix le